all right we're out of money that's it
uh I have to shut down the litter social
network that I made a few videos ago it
was uh very fun to see what people
submitted but it was also very very
unsustainable I have put up the uh
website you can essentially get all the
posts that were ever made and it is so
cool uh to see what comes out of this I
don't have the original posts I always
deleted them immediately after do doing
the whole conversion thing because
there's no fun getting into data
questions or anything like this so
anything here is completely generated
from abstract ideas of people that
submitted it you can see that there's
variations on pictures there's very cool
made stuff there is posts it's there's
memes people have submitted quite a few
that I have no clue what the original
pictures to any of these were absolutely
fantastic so how much was this actually
going in total we got about
1,500 posts that came through and we had
many many many more submitted and we
kept running into open AI rate Limits
The Vision preview API specifically has
a rate limit of 5 per minute and 500 per
day so that pretty quickly got hit yeah
that that was the main problem if you
submitted something and it didn't show
up after like 30 seconds that was the
reason ultimately I spent about uh I
guess 120ish bucks on open AI plus 20
bucks on a Reddit Cloud sorry reddis
Cloud
subscription ah Reddit hello if you're
watching and uh about 20 bucks on a
versel pro subscription because I didn't
want to run into uh rate limit problems
on either of these places which means I
spent about what is that 160ish I made
about 30 bucks in ad revenue from the
video so in total every single post
right here costs about 10 cents I feel
like that's a pretty good ratio I feel
like with that I could definitely go to
a venture capitalist I probably have to
up that burn a little bit to just be a
true AI startup but you know Sequoia if
you're listening now the the Investments
are open here we can keep this going all
we need is users we'll figure out how to
monetize this later definitely for sure
uh in the meantime you cannot submit
anymore I'm sorry but you can look at
the stuff that was generated and yeah it
was a fun time thanks to everyone who
participated and we'll see uh about the
the next Shenanigans finnally um on
Reddit someone actually had the idea
that led me to this whole thing the
original idea was to Only Store the
embeddings so to take like encoders for
text and image and Only Store the
embeddings and then every person who
looks at it it will be kind of rendered
for them in real time but that's just
way too slow currently but in a year or
two this might be totally viable and we
might want to revisit that then because
I definitely think that that is actually
the next iteration of this and and a
pretty cool idea because all you end up
storing is just an abstraction every
time you look at it it's is different
yeah that's that I'll see you around for
next bits and pieces and stay safe
bye-bye
he